I have known simply learn for many many
years so when I decided to have skill
myself and take a course in cyber
security I knew where to take it from
and it was exactly what I expected to be
you know tell me how to make the phone
better
of new clients for my company hey I'm
Gautama beer I
part of that Indonesia being a director
of ID
advisory at one of the biggest
accounting dance comes with their own
challenges so I have brown on them with
take the security of our clients
extremely serious as a senior person I
found a course in cyber security would
make me more
so I decided to take the host Railway
program in cyber security web modules
from MIT the instructions your training
courses and the type of content
really helpful I thought the recorded
sessions are during the weekdays and
live sessions on the weekends it really
helped me um
cleaning
for new clients and and getting new ones
so the course also helped me with the
current projects that I'm handling
some of them were really little IP
auditing services to others Fortune 500
companies I've attained a lot of
certifications as you can see on my
LinkedIn profile and it was further
helped me getting new clients but that's
why my lean account has over then 13 000
followers I use a link in to express
myself rather than doing practices I
like to share my knowledge with everyone
around
I'm also a master program in
undergraduate program
gas lectures for several Americans on
Indonesian universities I provided over
them six thousand hours of training
across Indonesia and Asia Pacific I
believe that we should strive to become
the best versions of ourselves